[Music]
um
you got shot before damn bro I always
wanted to get shot huh
I always wanted to just to feel it just
in my leg or something I never wanted to
take something in the chest you know
oh crazy bro but I always wanted to feel
careful what you wish for though
yeah maybe we'll take that part
no leave it in there all right yeah
you gotta go talk to the man up there he
said you know what man
yeah I was just having a good time I
didn't really mean that [__] uh yeah
that's true I need to bring that up
but yeah I always want to I think I you
know you always always want to have
experiences that I never had I never got
to smoke crack I've never been shot and
bro you can go smoke crack like I know I
know but now it's like I don't drink or
anything now so I feel like I would
really have to go back into that space
like if you want some crack let me know
I can get you something really yeah damn
you know people that smoke it
yeah yeah
oh so let me know what you want to do
okay
um take me through that experience of
getting shot man is it okay if I ask you
about it
yeah
y'all talked about it before
like what you mean take the experience
like like did you were you expecting to
get shot or it was a surprise
it was kind of a surprise
like you know I'm saying I knew it was
like some [__] going on
but um
like
like I ran out
trying to like you know what I'm saying
Toronto
trying to do something and then I ended
up getting shot oh yeah
and where did it hit you at the bullet
they hit me
my hip and then like
stomach like you know like pubic hair
[__] yeah yeah dude like damn
right there on a dick like on top of it
bro I got like three bullet holes and
[__] you still got the bullets in you no
no no
damn bro and did it hurt
yeah that [__] early yeah all right well
my [__] was like it's like all flush
like you didn't hit no bone or nothing
none of that so like you know what I'm
saying like
my [__] could have been worse way worse
yeah
and did you go to the doctor or you have
a friend take it out no I went to the
hospital I went to the hospital
dang bro that's heavy man do you feel
like it gave you more Street Credit
after that like at that point do you
feel like man I think
at this point we paid our dues you know
nah I don't like getting shot don't get
these Street Credit
like or the [__] that's doing
the shooting to get the street created
damn but like
like the situation that happened
like
the [__] Who start shooting
they end up
getting chased up up out of there you
know what I'm saying yeah
and whatever happened to them did you
ever see them again or see them
either online or anything
nah we still be trying to figure out
like who the [__]
bro
y'all saying that's the coldest [__]
ever yeah it is because you know I'm
saying now it's like
you just on on you got your guard up at
all times because you don't know
you coming across people like and it's
already like you would like have some
weird Vibes with somebody
and then you would be just you're just
thinking like is this [__]
something to do with that [__] you know
yeah
oh yeah man you
know I could see that easy being kind of
like suspecting everybody a little bit
dang
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one